and how long have you guys been together
months what kind of a girl goes Mexico
with a guy after two months oh just
drive Jade as perky fun serious and a
very organized Jake is really really
sweet super goofy which I really like
I almost exclusively date people with
man buns it just kind of happens that
way
so I'm a big fan I have been on vacation
with significant other before we broke
up shortly afterwards where the cruise
you can't leave each other like you're
on a ship you can't just get off the
ship
worst case scenario would be me both
leave with other people [ __ ]
so I was thinking we could finish up
breakfast here and then I would get a
pedicure if you want you can come with
me
I don't let it go AGP okay why did you
both those things
oh yeah let's just a boat okay
yet some issues with the gears her feet
were like too small to lever the shifter
gun to fix the gear issue then it was
just fun right before we hit the puddles
I was like oh it's gonna be a big splash
even though we got dirty mitosis took
listening she doesn't have her razors so
he's using the razor that I used to
shave my legs to shave his face skin
he's been doing this for like ten
minutes a long time it was definitely
important especially when it's like
close quarters like this I was gonna go
maybe up to the top deck and really go
for a run and stuff it is we can like
take a second and then I can meet back
in the room did your lipstick on it that
dinner last night
yeah the chef's table is pretty amazing
I've never seen food like that before it
was just absolutely delicious yeah I
definitely used to be picky I'm not a
really picky eater I was a vegetarian
for five years figured out she's a
vegetarian which is like a huge bummer
at some point but it's it's cool
how adorable I feel like you definitely
got a passing grade for the vacation
test initially I was a little bit
worried about how kind of easygoing and
spontaneous you were being about the
whole trip that ended up working out
really well and I sort of enjoyed just
kind of having time to do whatever and
figure it out as we go I did things I
never would have done normally on the
vacation like get a pedicure
that was almost who's you going on a
trip with me yeah yeah I go to vacation
again you never know what's gonna happen
but I think this is a good start
you